you know it's funny I was just talking
with my friend about watching Idol this
season and the way that they're doing it
in amidst this crisis did you ever
imagine
I ever imagined that this is this was
gonna be like your Idol experience like
definitely not like we were all I
remember like being in the room with
everybody and them telling us okay guys
we gotta fly home like the corona virus
just it's not safe for us to be here
anymore and like all of us like our jaws
just dropped and we were like like we
had no idea we're gonna be sent home and
it was like and like obviously the
corona virus it had kind of started but
we didn't I don't think anyone realized
how crazy it was and we were up every
morning and late every night like we
weren't sitting there watching the news
you know what I mean so for me I didn't
know that people were like you know
passing away and that it was such a huge
thing I thought it was just like a
sickness that was kind of going around a
little bit and then once we got sent
home everyone was like this is a really
big deal like oh my goodness so we had
no idea we're gonna be sent home no yeah
I mean above all else you know that
you're gonna be part of an historic
season yeah it was hard for everyone to
you know settle in being like oh my
goodness we're not like with each other
but I think what everyone looked past
that we were like this is so cool and
we're gonna be gonna go down with
history for us yeah but I gotta say
you've been knocking it out of the park
just just killing it and to know to be
like this girl is from Canada and to be
able to say that has been such a cool
thing what's the response been for you
yeah just the response from everybody
has just been crazy support um like
people just from like all over Canada
are like the Canadian girl only gonna
excuse from Canada and like everyone's
been so supportive I've had so many
positive comments and you know tweets
like everything everyone's just been so
kind yeah what was it like for you doing
that first audition in front of the
judges like auditioning for in front of
Lionel Richie that it's wild to me and
then getting and then getting that
feedback that you got that like such
positive feedback yeah I wasn't
um I was like nervous to be in front of
them but I wasn't nervous to you know
sing but I remember I was like I felt
like I couldn't breathe that guy's like
oh I'm in front of Katy Perry
am I gonna like they're just like
staring
like it's just like look at the floor
I'm gonna like freak out too much I was
like trying not to like fangirl over
them because I was a kid so I love the
immediate generation gap down I was like
land rich in your legaia Katy Perry so
have you been in I mean you must have
been in contact or must still be in
contact with the other contestants your
friends like how are things going what
are you guys talking about yeah I know
we've all been in contact since I'm like
I think on all of the top 20 especially
it's all just a big family off FaceTime
we all talk everyone knows what each
other's gonna saying like we have group
chats you know like everyone everyone's
really close and everyone's really
stating contact which is super good
considering that was something they're
all really worried about is that we
weren't gonna be with each other but you
know we've managed to stay all connected
at once um I think mainly all we talk
about is music and if we're not talking
about music or writing music or we're
singing to each other we're singing each
other our songs that we're gonna sing
and giving each other advice like oh
yeah so I mean with this time at home
have you been has it been particularly
music focused or have you been learning
other skills like people are baking
people are taking up gardening people
are doing all these things that they
maybe didn't have time to do before are
you getting involved in anything now um
I want to say I've done anything that
you know like super crazy that I've
never done before mainly
yeah music focused but I just been
working out a lot and like since my
audition I lost like a ton of weight and
so everyone on my social media had been
noticing that so I'm like okay now I
gotta keep the way focusing on that when
I was in school I didn't necessarily
have enough time to you know go to
school the whole day and then come home
and do music and go to the gym without
you know gonna make a full hours of
sleep so I think it's nice that I'm I've
been going a lot of hikes and like
walking my dogs and spending time with
my family so yeah and I think that that
home cooking so it's gonna be extra
extra challenging so when you look at
your career and the career that you're
gonna have do do you think about any
artists
that you are a fan of that you say I
want to have a career like that yeah I
really I mean like music-wise um like I
love Adele and her music and that kind
of you know side of it but people wise
and like sending a message I I really
look up to Billie Eilish and someone
who's not in music I really look up to
Ellen like if I had such a big platform
and want to be able to do things that
help other people and you know like
benefit the world in a good way and
spread a lot of like you know positivity
and love yourself like I want to have
like a message like that and I think
Billie Eilish puts a message out you
know be yourself wear whatever you want
like she wears big clothing because
she's like people don't need to look at
my body like I don't need to be
criticized for that kind of thing and I
think that's something that is super big
as you get judged on your body and I
love that she you know has created this
whole new thing like you don't get to
look at it like whoo there's no and
she's just created a whole new thing and
she's such an influence for a lot of
young girls my age and even younger to
just be themselves and I like that she
does that and I think it's important
when you're becoming a new artist now to
set an example like that for other
people when you look back on your
experience with this season of Idol what
do you think that you will take away the
most like what lessons do you think that
you've learned from it what moments
definitely I think we've all learned
like I came from a town where not a lot
of people do music and not a lot of
people staying so obviously like we're
taking back memories and like all these
fun times that we had with everyone and
I had so many fun times just like
singing with other people and
harmonizing that's something I never got
to do but I think a big lesson we learn
is just from watching other people sing
and perform you might have not been
focusing on those certain aspects of
your voice or your performance like for
me I always kind of just like stood and
saying and I was like that's just my
thing I just kind of stand there or like
you know I sit and then when I saw all
the other girls you know like strutting
around and like performing I was like I
really need to start performing on the
stage so I think just from being around
everybody everyone learn different
lessons of like different aspects of
their voice and their performance and
overall I think we all learned a huge
thing about just like accepting
everybody and not comparing yourself to
others and always staying true to who
you are so especially in front of the
camera because I know that people can
become or try to be different in front
of the camera and think that's that's
something that the public wants but I
think we all learned that we need to
just be ourselves and that's what's
going to get us through their
competition is being who we are